okay so today we're going to compare and
contrast autosomal recessive inheritance
versus autosomal dominance let's get
started okay so you might recognize this
picture as what's called a karyotype a
picture of a person's chromosomes now
chromosome 23 are called the sex
chromosomes because they influence and
have genes on them that determine our
gender the other 22 chromosomes are
called autosomes an autosome is a non
sex chromosome there are no genes on
these chromosomes that influence gender
and so when we study genetics we often
study autosomal recessive and autosomal
dominant disorders these are actual
disorders that are caused by an
afflicted gene that can be found on an
autism for instance you might have heard
of the disease of the disorder called
cystic fibrosis the gene that causes it
has been located on chromosome 7
chromosome 7 is an autosome and that's
why cystic fibrosis is an autosomal
disorder Huntington's disease is another
example of an autosomal disorder because
the gene is on chromosome 4 which is an
autosome sickle-cell disease is another
example of an autosomal disorder the
gene for sickle-cell has been found on
chromosome 11 chromosome 11 is an autism
you know that's different than let's say
hemophilia hemophilia is a disorder
where the the gene has been located on
one of the sex chromosomes haemophilia
is what's called a sex-linked disorder
so when we study autosomal disorders and
autosomal dominant autosomal recessive
it's because the gene is on one of the
22 autosomes chromosomes
okay so let's compare and contrast two
different families here the family on
the left we're going to use as an
example of a family who will be
experienced in an autosomal recessive
disorder and the family on the right
will be experienced in an autosomal
dominant disorder let's start with the
left autosomal recessive one of the most
basic rule
of an autosomal recessive disorders that
sufferers of these disorders must
inherit two alleles in order to have the
disorder they must inherit an allele
from the dad and from the mom this makes
healthy dominant and having the disorder
is then recessive so because healthy is
dominant I like to use a capital H
capital letters represent dominant
alleles and recessive we use lowercase
letters to represent recessive alleles
well examples of disorders that are
autosomal recessive would be for
instance sickle-cell disease cystic
fibrosis phenylketonuria abbreviated as
PKU and albinism these are all examples
in order to suffer from cystic fibrosis
you must inherit not one but two alleles
one from the mom one from the dad so if
a child were to inherit a dominant
allele from the dad dad and a dominant
allele from the mom this common
combination is called homozygous
dominant the child would be born healthy
they would not have for instance cystic
fibrosis or sickle cell or albinism but
if the dad well let's look at what
happens if the dad passes on a dominant
allele and let's look what happens if
the mom passes on a recessive allele now
because the child still has one healthy
dominant allele one capital H the child
will be healthy this combination is
called heterozygous the child would be
healthy although we would call them a
carrier because they still carry the
recessive allele in their DNA they could
ultimately pass it on to their child
when you know 25 years down the road
when this person that when this child
has a kid of his or her own so what
happens if the dad passes on the
recessive allele and also the mom passes
on the recessive allele
this combination is called homozygous
recessive and this is the only way a
child could inherit an autosomal
recessive disorder
such as sickle cell or cystic fibrosis
you have to inherit not one recessive
allele but two that's someone that
that's one of the most basic rules of an
autosomal recessive inheritance pattern
so how does this differ from autosomal
dominance let's look at the family on
the right now sufferers of disorders
that are autosomal dominant if you
suffer from the disorder you only have
to inherit one allele in order to have
the disorder
this makes the disorder the dominant
trait and therefore sadly healthy is
recessive so when I look at my key
notice how the key has changed the
disorder is represented by the dominant
capital H and being healthy is
represented by the lowercase recessive H
examples of autosomal dominant disorders
would be Huntington's disease you might
hear it called HD for Huntington's
disease and one called I hope I'm
pronouncing this right familial
hypercholesterolemia or you might also
hear it it's called FH these are two
examples of autosomal dominant disorders
so if a father passes on a dominant
capital H allele and the mom passes on a
dominant capital H allele this child
would be born with a homozygous dominant
disorder maybe Huntington's disease may
BER
maybe the familial hypercholesterolemia
and to make matters even worse if this
person was if this child were born with
a homozygous dominant capital H capital
H let's say it's Huntington's disease
we're talking about
well this condition is so severe because
they inherited not one of the of the
disordered alleles but two not one of
the defected alleles but two chances are
this child would experience very early
death usually only a couple years of
life and they just don't live into the
adulthood years of life so it's really
sad well what if the father passed on a
dominant allele and what if the mother
passed on a recessive allele now this is
still called heterozygous but notice how
the child still has the disorder they
inherited one dominant H and notice
the key the capital H represents the
disorder well this is still for instance
Huntington's disease heterozygous what
Huntington's disease but the difference
being is that this version is more
moderates that is severe as capital H
capital H homozygous dominant for
instance people who have Huntington's
disease and are born heterozygous they
typically will live a fairly normal life
up until maybe around age 40 or so when
they start to show signs of Huntington's
disease and then ultimately there's a
downhill progression where the disease
eventually claims their life but though
at least live into their adulthood years
to maybe have a family have a family and
have children of their own and so the
only way to actually be healthy if you
have a autosomal dominant disorder in
your family is to inherit not one
recessive healthy allele from the dad
but also a recessive allele from the man
homozygous recessive is the only way in
which you which you would have you know
healthy phenotype so let's solve a
couple punnett squares here autosomal
recessive on the left first if I said a
father was heterozygous capital H
lowercase H and I also said the mother
was heterozygous capital H lowercase H I
then fill in the punnett squares this
would create a healthy phenotype fill in
the punnett square again this would
create another healthy phenotype
although they'd be a carrier they're
still healthy fill in the punnett square
again here we have another healthy
phenotype again the child could be I
would be a carrier and then the only way
to actually have the disorder is if you
were homozygous recessive lowercase H
lowercase H so now for the autosomal
dominant side pretend we have a man
who's heterozygous for Huntington's
disease well he's heterozygous and he
has the moderate form of Huntington's
disease he's clearly an adult old enough
to marry and have children so he must
the moderate version same for the mom
what if the mom was heterozygous she too
would have the moderate version perhaps
of Huntington's disease and when we do
the punnett square we see oh no they can
actually have a child with the severus
form of Huntington's disease they could
also have a child with the moderate
version of Huntington's disease and in
the next punnett square we can see they
could have a child with the moderate
version of the disorder so notice three
out of four squares would result in a
child with Huntington's disease and
there's only a one out of four chance
that they would have a healthy child so
if the disorder is dominant you only
have to inherit one of the alleles but
on the left side if the disorder is
recessive you have to inherit not one
but two in order to have the disorder so
let's do a couple more practice problems
on the Left pretend we have a family
with a history of PKU
now the man's story says he's a
heterozygous carrier now he's got to be
one of these three genotypes which
genotype would be a heterozygous carrier
well it's not capital H capital H and
it's not lower H lower H heterozygous
means one capital letter one lower case
letter and so there's the genotype of
the man now the woman suffers from PKU
according to the story so she's one of
these three genotypes which genotype
would be a sufferer of a autosomal
recessive disorder such as PKU it's not
capital H capital H that's a healthy
woman or healthy man even and it's not
capital H lowercase H because that too
would be a healthy person the only way
to suffer from PKU would be to be would
be if you were homozygous recessive so
when we fill in the punnett square we
can see that as the squares get filled
in we can see that this man and woman
have a 50% chance of having a healthy
child who's a carrier and a 50% chance
of having a child with the disorder PKU
now for the family on the right pretend
they have a history of Huntington's
disease now the man is one of these
three genotypes now the story says the
man's healthy so which combination would
give us a healthy individual it's not
capital H capital H because the disorder
is dominant it's not capital H lowercase
H because again the disorder would be
dominant the only way to be healthy is
if you're homozygous recessive now for
the woman the woman's one of these three
genotypes now which one is she the story
says she's a sufferer of Huntington's
disease if she has the disease I know
she's not lower H lower H so which one
is it both of the two that are left
would be a person with the disorder the
difference being she cannot be capital H
capital H because that's the severe
version where they just don't live into
their adulthood years clearly the story
implies that she's an adult woman
married old enough to have kids of room
she must have the heterozygous moderate
version of the disorder so as the
punnett squares get filled in we can see
that they have a 50% chance of having a
child with the moderate version of the
disorder and they have a 50% chance of
having a child that's healthy but
because the disorder is dominant the end
of individuals only need to inherit one
allele to receive the disorder but on
the left side they have to inherit not
one but two in order to have the
recessive disorder so I want to leave
this up here for you to compare and
contrast just the summary pause the
video if you'd like to you know review
the summary in a little more detail and
I'd love to hear your comments in the
box below so I hope you found this
helpful thanks for watching